[Music]  today's lottery hopefuls have another  slim chance at becoming a  multi-millionaire tonight's Powerball  jackpot drawing has jumped to at least  825 million dollars it's the second  largest prize in Powerball history no  one has matched all six numbers since  August 3rd but if you beat the one in  292 million odds of winning it all  tonight you can get your Millions spread  over 29 years or choose the cash out  option which is worth an estimated 410  million dollars so you're saying there's  a chance there's always a chance if you  play would you share  it's in how much do you want me to share  a third yeah you want me to give a third  of the money if y'all pitch in I don't  know